This video is sponsored by Curiosity Stream.
If you've seen Dune already this clip probably
feels different from what you remember. It's
because I removed the score.
I've seen many people talk about the
film's imagery and it's very impressive
but the first thing that greets you in this movie,
before you even see the studio logos, is sound.
And I think both the score and
the sound design play a huge role
in making Denis Villeneuve's new adaptation
of Dune the experience that it is. I had a
great time watching Dune and walking out of the
theater one of the things I was most excited
about was the film's score. The sound design
and Hans Zimmer's score add a huge amount of
scale and texture to the world. It's wild and
completely unlike anything else I've heard.
Some of the sounds he created for this
score are truly kind of terrifying.
It uses layers and layers of voices, singing,
chanting, whispering, yelling, throat singing,
along with sounds from instruments that genuinely
look like they could have come from Geidi Prime
I fell in love with the score
and what it brought to the film
so naturally, I wanted to watch Dune without it.
By controlling which of the surround sound
channels are active in a video editor we can
get a sense of what a scene would be like
without the dialogue or without the score
so I watched through a bunch of scenes with just
the score and no dialogue and just the dialogue
and no score to see what I could learn about
the score and the role it plays in the film.
For Dune's score, Zimmer wanted to invoke
sounds that felt like they came from a place
thousands of years in the future he didn't want
the audience to ever hear a full orchestra and
instead wanted to focus on using sounds that
felt like they came from the world of Dune.
Typically in a score, you might
have a melodic theme or a motif
represent a character or a place but
for this adaptation of Dune Zimmer
leans away from that. He definitely
uses certain melodic or rhythmic themes:
Like the rhythmic drum hit,
repeated throughout the film,
in a variety of ways. Often
prefacing action or conflict
But Zimmer focuses more on
connecting certain kinds of sounds to
groups influences or settings and then using those
sounds to invoke those things he relates the
insane grinding rhythmic throb with the Harkonnen.
He uses this whispery female
chanting for the Bene Gesserit.
House Atreides gets more
traditional, warmer sounds.
"I told my father I didn't want this either."
So while Duncan Idaho has his own little theme,
it also has a sonic connection to the sound
Zimmer is using for House Atreides as a whole.
And the desert and the Fremen get higher
pitch sounds that invoke wind and sand,
wind instruments like flutes, as
well as vocalization that is distinct
from the whispery high-pitched
singing of the Bene Gesserit.
So this is where it gets really brilliant
I think. Dune is a complicated story with a
lot of different things going on. There are
many competing forces, Paul, as a character
is struggling between different identities and
callings. And associating different sounds and
instruments with different ideas allows Zimmer
to actually bring these different forces into
conflict within a single piece or melody. For
example: once we associate this sound with the
Bene Gesserit and this kind of sound with House
Atreides and the Duke, listen to how these two
ideas come into play in the score during
this conversation alongside the dialogue.
"Will you protect our son?"
"With my life."
"I'm not asking his mother
I'm asking the Bene Gesserit."
When the Duke addresses Jessica as the Bene
Gesserit we hear the Bene Gesserit sounds come in.
"Will you protect Paul?"
And then when she tries to reassure
him we hear the House Atreides sound come in –but
it comes in on top of the Bene Gesserit sound. If
Zimmer had been relying here on a melody to
communicate these two ideas this would have
been a lot more difficult, but instead, both
can exist within the same piece simultaneously.
Another example is this scene: the higher-pitched
dentist drill sound represents the pain being
inflicted on Paul's hand by the box, and the
vocalizations represent something being awakened
deep within Paul. These two forces can actually
exist and come into conflict within the piece.
So we have the desert, the Bene Gesserit, the
Fremen, House Atreides, and various prophecies
represented in the score and Paul struggles
internally between all these roles and identities.
In the book, we can actually read this
play out in his internal monologue,
but in the film, they decided to stay away
from any kind of voice-over and so the score
helps bring that kind of internality onto the
screen.And that's not to say the score isn't
utilizing melodic themes, but Zimmer instead
of linking melodies to specific characters
(with the exception of maybe Duncan Idaho)
uses them more to illustrate plot lines.
There are complementary melodic motifs
that follow Paul throughout his journey
into the desert and because Zimmer is using
sound for locations and groups instead of melody
he can evolve how he's presenting that melody
depending on where Paul is in his journey. For
example: we're first introduced to this theme
that follows Paul's journey into the desert
with the warmer tones used for house
of tradies but there's also a sense of
mournfulness and longing as he awakens from
dreams of the planet arrakis and the desert
and then when paul is learning about the
fremen and the desert on arrakis we get this
same theme but it's a bit distorted as if
we're only getting a vague picture of the place
finally when paul is flying over the desert we
get the theme again but this time it's no longer
distorted it has a new intensity and it's lacking
that long quality as if to say this is my new home
this melody marks a certain element
the plot and the way it's portrayed
sonically gives that plot an emotional
arc zimmer uses another complimentary
melodic motif to represent pieces
of this same journey into the desert
look at how this moment
is linked to this one with both
a visual and a melodic motif
while the soundscape of voices and
instruments that zimmer uses for each moment
represents the two environments distinctly
these two complementary themes come together
in the final scene as paul advances even
deeper into the desert the track for
leaving calidan and the film's climax are very
similar but while paul is in kaladan the vocals
play more of a background role while the track
leans more heavily on the aggressive bagpipe
style sounds that were associating with house
atreides but for the film's climax in the desert
those sounds are still there but they fall to
the background while the vocals take the lead
another example of how this plays out is
with the benny desert order while they
don't spend much time on screen they play
a huge role in the story behind the scenes
they're not visually present in
the destruction of arakin but
we know from the story they've played a part in
orchestrating this betrayal so i love that their
influence on these events is felt through this
scene because of their inclusion in the score
similarly when the hunter seeker shows up
we're clued into the fact that it comes
from the harkonnens through the score
before their involvement is
revealed through the dialogue
the hawking agent was cemented
into that hole six weeks ago
let's talk about duncan idaho
and his theme for a moment as i
mentioned he's one of the few characters
that gets a very blatant melodic theme
but i think that this theme is used in a clever
way almost every time duncan shows up we hear
his theme but when he's sacrificing himself
to defeat the sardikar instead of hearing
his theme which would seem like the obvious
move here we get a nod to the fremen musically
and then when paul is going into combat with one
of the fremen we actually hear duncan's theme
and i think this helps to illustrate the
interconnectedness of everything duncan has
learned from the fremen and he uses that
knowledge here in defeating the sardicar
and duncan's theme here is a nod to the fact that
paul has learned to fight from duncan even though
we never actually see that in the film now i will
say if i have a critique here at all it's that i
think the score might be a little overused
in some moments i think it's a brilliantly
constructed score i love how it sounds but there
aren't many scenes without any score at all
watching some of these scenes especially more
intimate dialogue scenes without the score made
me feel like it might have been better to play
some of these moments with a little less score
ever since you brought him before your
reverend mother he hasn't been the same
he's distracted the film in many ways
feels kind of like it's rushing through
a bunch of setup when you drop the
score out of some of these scenes
it slows things down and gives the characters
a little more intimacy and room to breathe
and ironically i think doing this would actually
make the film score even more impactful when it is
used because the intensity would only be magnified
in contrast to the quieter more intimate scenes
but that's more of an issue with sound
editing than it is with the score
i think it's an incredible and inventive score
one that for me doesn't just help make the film
more exciting but actually adds complexity to
the story like denny villeneuve han zimmer has
been a longtime fan of the book and i think
his knowledge of the material shows through
his work it's not just a score that sounds
like it comes from a distant world in the
far future it's a score that takes the book's
metaphysical and mystical elements which take
a backseat in the dialogue and exposition
in the film and weaves them into the story
for me the success of this score is the way
it adds to the dramatic conflict of the story
and the way it takes part in the world building
sounding like it's an artifact of the world itself
while watching the film to dissect the score
i discovered some cool ways sound design and
mixing are used in the film like how they got
the baron's voice to just sound so terrifying
so i've decided to make a companion video
to this one that breaks those elements down
you can watch it right now on nebula nebula is
a streaming service built and owned by creators
and the best way to get nebula and access to that
video is with the curiosity stream nebula bundle
which you can get for less than 15 a year when
you sign up using my link below on nebula you
can see bonus exclusive content from me like my
breakdown of dude sound design or my video about
omar little's code from the wire but you'll
also get access to all my usual videos
early and without any ads or sponsors when you
sign up for the bundle using my link you'll
also get access to curiosity stream where you'll
find a ton of educational and documentary content
if you're interested in seeing very real stunning
desert visuals you could check out the documentary
africa's desert storms on curiosity stream right
now this bundle is an amazing deal for less than
fifteen 15 for an entire year you'll get access
to two streaming services full of amazing content
signing up and watching on nebula helps support
myself and other independent creators like me
click the link on the screen to sign up now
and watch my video on dunes sound design